[Music]
all the studies show it's a bit of a
slippery slope so i mentioned earlier i
think it's 80
of children who just have therapy
eventually settle into the biological
sex there was a study done on children
who take puberty blockers and in this
study over 90 percent of those children
went on to take cross-sex hormones so we
have to think about what's going on here
actually if we leave them be they settle
into themselves if we start them down
this path of irreversible puberty
blockers they're on a one-way street
towards kind of full medical
transitioning
are you tired of using bulky old wallets
giving you a bulge where you don't want
it to be my old wallet was massive so it
brought all the ladies to the yard which
was a huge distraction and got in the
way of my esteemed work on trigonometry
bridge wallets have an incredible
solution for you this is mine sleek
stylish and with an industrial look to
it you can fit 12 cards with cash on the
back using a clip like this one or a
strap we've got one for the whole team
i've got one francis has one even our
producer anthem has one but he's from
liverpool so he flogged his on the black
market the great thing about ridge is
that they give you a lifetime guarantee
which means if you want you can have
only one wallet for the rest of your
life ridge are so confident in the
quality of their product they will give
you 45 days to test drive their wallets
that means you can get the wallet use it
and if you don't like it you can return
it within 45 days because ridge are such
great guys they're going to give you 10
off and free worldwide shipping and
returns to take advantage of this
incredible offer go to ridge.com forward
slash trigger that's ridge.com forward
slash trigger and use our special code
which is of course trigger
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
francis foster i'm constantine kitten
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with fascinating
people our brilliant guest today is a
former child line counselor and a
trainee psychotherapist james lester's
welcome to trigonometry thank you very
much thanks for having me it's great to
have you on the show uh we've got you've
got an interesting story to tell us so
why don't we just get straight into that
tell everybody a little bit about who
are you how are you where you are and
most importantly what is it
part of your journey that brings you to
be sitting here talking to us sure
so yes the last few years have been
quite surreal for me i started off my
career as a criminal barrister working
in the law
i didn't find it as fulfilling as i
thought it might i wanted to do
something else i decided on a whim to
take up a volunteering counselling role
at child line the children's charity
where i was counseling young people
every week for almost about five years
and i found that so fulfilling that i
decided i wanted it to become my life
and i decided to undertake training to
become a psychotherapist
until last year i was three years into a
master's degree in psychotherapy but i
was beginning to get concerned about the
issue of sex and gender in relation to
children and particularly young children
struggling from gender dysphoria and
being told that they were trapped in the
wrong bodies and i immersed myself in
the research and the literature and the
studies on this topic and i just became
more and more concerned about what was
happening i decided i had to do
something to kind of speak out about
this the government were proposing
banning conversion therapy and there was
a concern that this could step into
banning ethical explorative therapy for
these children who are really struggling
so i launched a government petition
asking them to safeguard therapy
uh within a few months i'd been expelled
from my master's degree
over email and also let go from my
volunteering role at childline
um so i feel that i've
i'm the perfect example of cancer
culture in relation to this sex and
gender debate which is so sensitive but
so important well we'll talk about that
part of it in a second but you know when
you said you you became
concerned about this issue
was it because you were sort of online
mainlining youtube videos about trans or
were you or was your concern prompted by
what you were seeing in your counseling
work
very much the latter as i said i was
doing this for five years and every year
that went by there were more and more
children coming through on a weekly
basis saying that they felt that they
were trapped in the wrong body and they
were also younger and younger in age
and i'd be speaking to some 10 11 year
olds
who were telling me that they were trans
and that they wanted to transition
and when i was gently trying to explore
with them what does trans mean what does
puberty mean what what does sex and
gender mean
they couldn't even offer up
a coherent answer because they were far
too young actually but they did know
they were trans
even though they didn't know those other
things they for some reason knew they
were trans
correct well that this is what they were
saying
um
clearly they were in a state of distress
it wasn't my role to judge of course and
it wasn't my role either to advise
my role was to explore as we would for
any other mental health condition or
situation which somebody is struggling
within themselves
but
coupled with this is
the potentially irreversible path these
children are going down and i'm sure we
can get onto this a bit but
you know i was hearing about these
children wanting to be put on puberty
blockers and then wanting to progress
onto cross-sex hormones and even
irreversible surgery
and this was concerning for me because
as soon as i started reading the studies
on this i was seeing that for the vast
majority of children if left untouched
and just offered explorative therapy
they will settle into themselves and
their biological sex
but
unfortunately once children start on
puberty blockers again the studies show
that it's a bit of a slippery slope
towards further medicalization
it's such a
a red-hot sensitive topic for
understandable reasons
did you know were you not aware james of
what you were getting yourself into when
you started to speak out or did you just
simply think that this was something
that you had to do
i i didn't think what i was saying was
particularly controversial and i was
coming at this from a therapeutic point
of view because i was training to be a
therapist and the idea of offering
open exploration for the clients that
are in front of us but i was finding
that gender dysphoria we can talk about
the meaning of that maybe in a bit but
it was being treated in a way that was
quite different to any other mental
health condition
for me it was the only condition which
the proposed treatment was to affirm
the distressing thoughts inside
somebody's head
if we compared something like body
dysmorphia for example where people
think that they're potentially hugely
obese or extremely unattractive
the the way for a therapist to engage
with that is not to say yes you're right
um
but actually here we were being told and
almost instructed by our training
institutes to affirm somebody so if they
say they're in the wrong body
they must be
and
why do you think that is why do you
think that we've gone down this path
because as you said
every other therapy or every other
condition you wouldn't affirm what the
person is saying if they have body
dysmorphia but why is it with gender
dysphoria we do that
i mean there's a few reasons for that i
think
part of it i think is out of
a desire to be seen to be polite and to
be respectful and i support those aims
but i think it goes too far so for
example i had a conversation with a
senior clinician who's working with
children in this space recently
and they said that they are very mindful
about using language that is potentially
offensive even if it's medically
incorrect so an example of that is and i
see this all the time particularly in
school resources
telling children that sex is assigned at
birth
so this is this is factually medically
untrue
sex isn't designed at birth it's
observed it's recorded
but this clinician said that she would
continue to use this language even
though it was medically incorrect
because she didn't want to offend young
people and for me that's a serious
concern
and we we use the term gender dysphoria
what does it actually mean to have
gender dysphoria what is gender
dysphoria
it's a recognized mental health
condition
it's basically a mismatch between
how one feels about themselves and their
actual physical body
um and often accompanying this is kind
of significant amount of distress
understandably you know crucially in the
uk in order to legally transition or in
order to medically transition you must
be diagnosed with gender dysphoria
and this i find interesting because the
other side of the argument always say
you shouldn't pathologize being trans
there's absolutely nothing wrong with it
at the same time they say you must offer
us potentially irreversible medication
and surgery to deal with this and for me
that's wholly inconsistent and
you know you can't have it both ways and
this is one of the the reasons that i
think this issue is so difficult to talk
about but also so so necessary to talk
about because i've said from day one the
trans issue is what will break a lot of
this whole thing that we talk about and
have talked about on the show a lot
because
i am
deeply liberal when it comes to live
your life the way you want to live it be
who you want to be etc but when you
start
talking about children and taking them
on the path you're inevitably going to
end up with what we are now seeing which
we've all been predicting for some time
which is there will be large numbers of
people who are de-transitioning who
regret what they did who regret being
encouraged and doing and we will get
people like that on the show to talk
about it um
so there was a lot in in the desire to
be polite in a desire to be
accommodating and desire to be affirming
damage was done
and probably continues to be done but do
you feel that we've made progress in
reversing some of this craziness in
terms of you know we had marcus evans
from the tavistock clinic that's there's
been a report into that now which says
that it's completely unfair for the
purpose of helping children who are
suffering in this way uh and other
things have happened recently i think
with stonewall also where
the government and institutions are sort
of starting to to realize this isn't a
clear-cut issue of being nice to people
there's some real concerns do you think
we're making progress
very slowly it does feel that the tide
is beginning to turn
but
i'm inundated daily with emails from
concerned parents
revealing to me what has been taught to
their very young children at school what
they've been exposed to online
the organizations or charities that
they're engaging with give us some
examples
um
okay i can talk about some resources
that i've come across that have been
taught in primary and secondary schools
which very much seems to be a way of
getting gender identity in through the
back door so for example a parent
flagged a module to me
in a computing class
for young people i think the age was
about 13 14.
and the class was for the purpose of
describing children how computing
language works which is in binary coding
the teaching instructions that the
teachers were meant to utilize
wanted them towards the end of the class
to emphasize that computing language can
be distinguished from human beings who
are inherently non-binary in gender
what gender identity theory has to do
with computing language is beyond me but
that's very much trying to i think
infiltrate and get this uh ideology into
the back door
i've come across primary schools using
books and resources suggesting to
children
a that sex is assigned at birth but b
if they are for example a young boy who
likes the color pink or wants to grow
their hair longer or they're a young
girl who likes to play football that
actually rather than just being
gender atypical they might actually be
trapped in the wrong body um
i could go on there's um
it's it's quite strange really there's a
there's a page from a book talking about
pride and it's got flags all the
different flags from the different
genders and sexualities that there are
um all very colorful as we know and then
there's a box for straight and a box for
sis
it's just the blank white page
um
there's nothing there and i'm trying to
put myself in the shoes of a young
person and i can imagine that when
they're looking at all these bright
amazing colorful flags and then to be
cis and straight is just the white page
what young person would want to identify
with that i feel that it's been pushed
upon children is almost stale or boring
and i often see the word celebrate
in these school materials we should
celebrate being trans but i think about
all the young people in society who
aren't celebrated very often for just
being themselves
and now there might be an opportunity
for them to be celebrated simply for you
know coming out and saying i'm trans i'm
non-binary
it feels like a form of coercion
and do you do you really think that a
child would want to come out as
non-binary or trans in order to be
celebrated because
the reality is and as somebody who has
taught for many many years kids just
want to fit in kids don't really want to
stand out the vast majority of them they
just want to be part of the group and i
think we can say that that's how we were
when we were that age surely
i i i do take your point but
i don't agree i think the messaging
that's coming from a lot of these
organizations is very powerful mermaids
a charity that i'm particularly
concerned about and we can speak about
that in a bit and they've got a podcast
for young people and in a recent episode
the message they put out to young people
was if you are trans you are helping
society
who's not going to be influenced by this
particularly a young child and
particularly children who are in a state
of flux i mean when we think about
puberty
everything around you is changing your
entire being your physiology is changing
you're trying to discover yourself
and here you have people saying
you know basically come and join us and
you will be welcomed and you will be
potentially even celebrated i see a lot
of alienation as well from from people's
families so again mermaids in this
podcast
there was a question from a young person
about families struggling with
misgendering them and the the podcast
hosts
weren't
empathetic or tried to see it from a
parent's point of view they said
family isn't blood
what message is this sending to young
people
do you think that's part of the reason
why we've seen
more and more children trans
transitioning more and more children
identifying as you know non-binary
trans
do you think that's the reason or do you
just simply think it's part of it it's
also because we never talked about it it
was taboo therefore people didn't want
to say that they were that particular
identity
i i think it's a bit of both
uh in reality
the difficulty is that the pathway that
young people have put on right now
um
as i said all the studies show it's a
bit of a slippery slope so i mentioned
earlier i think it's 80
of children who just have therapy
eventually settle into the biological
sex there was a study done on children
who take puberty blockers and in this
study over 90 of those children went on
to take cross-sex hormones so we have to
think about what's going on here
actually if we leave them be they settle
into themselves if we start them down
this path of irreversible puberty
blockers they're on a one-way street
towards kind of full medical
transitioning
and we talked earlier about gender
dysphoria and you described it as a
recognized mental
health
how did you phrase it
mental health condition mental health
condition
um
what does that mean exactly because the
the reason i ask is you you are well
versed in all this stuff we less so and
a lot of people may be coming to this
issue for the first time and i think
this is probably the wrong way to look
at it but to a lot of people a mental
health condition
what that sounds like is this is
somebody's brain that's not working the
way that it should be working right um
so when you say it's a mental health
condition what does that mean exactly
well
i i think for many it can still be a
stigmatizing term
um but we have to think that mental
health conditions are quite diverse in
range and can range from basic anxiety
and depression all the way up to kind of
more serious mental health conditions
schizophrenia personality disorders etc
um
as i said
the reason this is a mental health
condition is because there's a mismatch
between one's physical body and how one
feels about themselves inherently and
the distress that comes along with that
so when i use that term and it's a
recognized term in the dsm which is
basically the international manual that
classifies mental health conditions um
that's simply there to recognize what
these individuals are going through but
again
gender dysphoria as far as i can see is
is the only mental health condition in
which potentially the proposed treatment
is to alter one's physical body
i mean if we take another example of
anorexia for example
the proposed treatment is not to undergo
liposuction
and for many that might be quite a stark
comparison but it's
it's much the same because these
individuals are feeling something about
the body
that
that isn't quite right there's another
condition you may have heard of it's
called body integrity identity disorder
i don't know if you've heard of that so
this is a condition it's quite a rare
condition but it's where people feel
that a piece of their body doesn't
belong to them almost that it's wrong or
that it's bad and
often they will want it to be amputated
they might just feel that their arm
shouldn't belong to them and they want
to get amputated
the nhs will not amputate your arm no
matter how much you hate it no matter
how much you feel it shouldn't belong to
you and isn't a part of you they will
not amputate your arm bigots
but i'm coming across studies and
stories of young people in the late teen
years been offered double mastectomies
by the nhs for gender dysphoria because
they feel that their breasts do not
belong to them
so
we're talking about things like puberty
blockers
what actually happens if you take
puberty blockers at the age of 12 13.
let's actually have that conversation
well the age you take it on is is
absolutely crucial actually
because for example if you take puberty
blockers in advance of starting puberty
and then you go on straight away from
that and transition it across sex
hormones your body is still technically
in a pre-pubescent state and so what
that can lead to is for example
infertility and this is happening more
and more actually so i think the age is
crucial and we're finding actually that
younger and younger children have been
offered these puberty blockers because
the message is we want this the
transition to be as smooth for you as
possible so let's let's halt things as
early as possible but that can have
significant ramifications particularly
if people later change their mind but
puberty blockers i mean
this is still experimental medication we
don't have long-term studies on lots of
this but it does what it says on the tin
i mean it basically holds one's puberty
what we don't know from the days and the
studies because it hasn't been around
long enough is the long-term effects
although i read a study recently
suggesting that puberty blockers are
causing potentially untold developmental
issues for these young people whether to
do with their bone growth and
development or even potentially the
brain development
well i mean look that makes complete
sense because when you go through
puberty your bones thicken and they
become stronger your muscles develop
both male and female so if you're
putting puberty blockers in
you don't you effectively have the body
of a child for the rest of your life
well
i think
again it depends you know if you come on
them if you come off them sorry
the expectation is that you will resume
a normal puberty now i would always
question what that is because if we have
interfered with the body's natural
function
you can never say that they have then
gone through a natural puberty because
they simply haven't but yes for many of
them depending on
how long they've been taking it etc it
can potentially affect their bodies
overall in terms of how they develop and
what about the counter argument don't
these puberty blockers help these kids
and don't they
uh you know have good outcomes as a
result of transitioning and you know we
we hear a lot about uh
which is true that
people who suffer from from gender
dysphoria in this way have a higher
suicide rate than the the rest of the
population and so and isn't this all
designed to help them alleviate some of
that awful distress that they're
experiencing
for some and that's why i've never
called for a complete ban on these forms
of treatment because i think for some
it is the only result although i think
when it comes to strong
experimental medication and then
irreversible surgery it should probably
be a last resort and my focus would
always want to be from a therapeutic
perspective but yes for some it probably
is appropriate but again i speak to many
parents who were told this message by
the school by the doctor by these
charities they allow the children to go
on puberty blockers to take the
cross-sex hormones even to end up having
surgery eventually and their children
are as suicidal as ever
and you bring up the point with parents
uh where are we in this country uh with
parental consent because that always
seemed to me i i don't know what the
case is in the uk and in england
specifically but the idea that for
example
parents are not being told that their
child
presents as a different gender whatever
that means in school and they're not
being told that or
parents being essentially forced to
consent on behalf of children to things
that they wouldn't consent if they
weren't sort of harassed into it or
whatever like that to me is always seems
strange
these are young people who who are not
allowed by law to make a decision about
whether to drink half a glass of beer
but they can take puberty blockers and
and take other drastic actions what is
the situation right now with that well
the point you just made is absolutely
crucial and i i can never get my head
around the fact that yes a child might
not be able to buy a lottery ticket or
even vote in an election but can consent
to potentially irreversible medication
that is experimental in nature you know
we do have to wonder what what's going
on here it's it's wholly inconsistent i
find parents being completely frozen
eight actually
give you some examples um i mentioned
mermaids earlier they've got a youth
forum it's kind of like a chat an online
chat room and there's moderators from
people who work at mermaids um i saw
some screenshots recently this young 13
year old girl had come through
and said that she was trans she didn't
like her breasts but her parents
wouldn't give her a breast binder
because there's health risks associated
with that
let's just stop a second yeah what does
that mean a breast binder
um
breast binders are basically materials
that are used to kind of compress one's
breasts and to give the appearance of
not having them it's often seen as kind
of an early stage towards potentially
transitioning
and what are the effects of that
on the body
significant uh and again studies have
shown that people can be left with
chronic pain uh back problems even
affecting breathing and lung
functionality and particularly
the young people who use them often want
to wear them for as long as possible
because they want to present as not
having breasts but actually the longer
you wear them if you don't wear them
under proper supervised guidance the
results can be quite quite bad indeed
um so we can see why a parent wouldn't
necessarily want the child using this
um anyway so this young person sent that
message on the forum
a mermaid's moderator an adult came back
straight away and offered to send out a
breast binder in the post anonymously
behind their parents back to them
wow
okay
i mean
whenever i touch upon this subject i
always find myself getting getting very
upset because
having taught and i taught secondary and
i also talked primary when you're
tilting about 10 and 11 year old
children they have no con concept of
consequences their brains haven't
developed to the point where they can
understand that certain actions have
consequences which is why children do
the things that they do
when are we going to start to have an
honest conversation about this james
because it's still it still seems to me
that we're dealing with narratives when
we talk about the trans issue
oh i mean we've we've robbed our
children
one of the beauties of childhood of
puberty of teenage years has always been
the ability to explore to try things out
i mean if we think back you know to
old-fashioned kind of
emos or goths or whatever you know it's
a time to just play around and explore
and figure out who you are in this world
and make mistakes and then
do something different what we've done
here
by forcing children at such a young age
to make potentially irreversible
decisions we've robbed them of the
opportunity to experiment regret and
then move on
um
your question was about how you know
when is the narrative going to change
i i i don't know um
and we'll come on to this in a bit but
you know i i spoke out about this
and i was cancelled i know many others
including many other therapists doctors
teachers who are raising concerns about
this in their own institutions who are
also being shut down
but i think if if the public at large
knew exactly what was going on
i think they'd be absolutely shocked and
before we move on
thing that i really want to talk with
with you about is what do you think
about the link with autism
and people who want to transition or
identify as trans because it now appears
particularly in girls that there's a
connection
significant connection i think
comorbidities are absolutely crucial
autism is a crucial one just to say
there are others for example previous
traumatic experiences
also internalized homophobia seems to be
quite a big one because actually the
majority of people who come out as trans
end up um coming out as gay and so
they're transiting away the gay
potentially well potentially i've heard
anecdotally that among some family units
they would far rather have a child who
is trapped in the wrong body and
straight than gay
the autism link is is particularly
concerning actually but again myself and
colleagues are often castigated for even
trying to draw a link between these
things
um it's very concerning so you the the
industry is not ready to have an
investigation into autism and trans and
what the links may be even though it's
very important because if somebody is
saying that they've got gender dysphoria
and they're autistic you might be able
to look at the autism as a reason why
they're feeling the gender dysphoria
well precisely so i mean hillary cass um
senior clinician is currently
undertaking an independent review into
um medicine and treatment for gender
identity amongst children and looking
into tavistock she released her interim
report actually a few weeks ago but this
is something that she is particularly
concerned about and has flagged it in
the report so i'm hopeful that that will
help to uncover a bit more about the
link between autism and gender dysphoria
and how we can best treat it going
forward but if if we're prevented as
clinicians from even having the
conversation in the first place there's
nowhere we can go
hey constantine do you want better
mental health i'm from russia we don't
have mental health so how do you deal
with mental health you drink vodka then
go out and wrestle bear if you live you
feel better if you die you're not real
men what about the bears feelings it's
russian bear it has no feelings people
don't always realize that physical
symptoms like headaches teeth grinding
and even digestive issues can be
indicators of stress and let's not
forget about doom scrolling not sleeping
enough sleeping too much under eating
and overeating sleeping too much under
eating this is western disease therapy
has really helped me in my life to
concentrate and focus it's really
important to have someone impartial who
you can talk to about the tricky issues
that you're struggling to deal with
therapy has played a really important
role in helping me to deal with my adhd
and become better in all areas of my
life
why is he telling them how weak he is
drink vodka feel better better help is
customized online therapy that offers
video phone and even live chat sessions
with your therapist so you don't have to
see anyone on camera if you don't want
to trigonometry funds get 10 off their
first month at betterhelp.com forward
slash trigger especially if they're not
real men that's b e t t e r h e l p dot
com slash trigger
uh so let's talk about your own story
then because it's not an unfamiliar one
to us on this show we've covered things
like this a lot
so
there you are a childline counselor yeah
you're starting to see that younger and
younger and greater numbers of children
are presenting with this issue
you start to become concerned you do
some research
what happens then
uh i do the research and i think i've
got to do something i have to try and
start a conversation about this and it
didn't feel that within the therapeutic
bodies i was operating within even my
own training institution that these
conversations were happening
um i co-founded a group that i'm part of
called thoughtful therapists who wanted
to explore this issue more as i said i
started a government petition
and what it said was government if
you're going to ban conversion therapy
which is an abhorrent practice please
safeguard explorative therapy for young
people
and the government actually responded we
got 10 000 signatures and the government
responded very favorably saying they
would protect the independence of
clinicians in this space which was
excellent but i attracted
negative attention online from
some pretty hardcore
trans activists i'm going to term them
as
um
so there's some noise online i i found
out that they've made some complaints
about me to my to my university
institution
um
and then one day out of the blue last
may i think it was a wednesday i
received an email from the from the
deputy ceo of my course and as i
mentioned i was just about to complete
my third year of this masters in fact
i'd just been
given permission to set up a private
practice in therapy so um things were
moving in the right direction for me
anyway this email said we've had some
complaints about you and your petition
and associate publicity can you come in
for an informal conversation
um now i was a bit taken aback by that
because i didn't feel i'd done anything
wrong but i said of course i will um and
i expressed my anxiety about being
called in for this it seemed quite out
of the blue and i had a response saying
please let me reassure you there's
absolutely nothing to be anxious about
whatsoever it is simply an informal chat
to discuss things
so it was scheduled for two days later
on on the friday
i hadn't been provided with any evidence
or anything at this stage i've just been
told there were these complaints
fast forward less than 24 hours later
onto the thursday
and an email drops into my inbox
entitled termination of contract
and it was a two paragraph email and it
told me in that that i was being
expelled with immediate effect from my
course and that the conversation on
friday would not be taking place
so you were getting expelled
immediately from your course why was
that
well they said because i brought them
into disrepute
again they didn't provide any evidence
of this whatsoever
i say and when we talk about my ongoing
litigation that it was because they were
discriminating against me because of my
beliefs in this space
i find it so difficult to believe james
that you started an online petition and
that immediately led to you getting
fined what was there no appeals process
could you not have said to them you know
you know this needs to go further higher
up the chain
uh
every step of the way they ignored and
flighted their own policies and
i i went to respond to the email
immediately to express my dismay i
thought surely they made a mistake you
know surely we can figure this out
uh they had already blocked my email
address so i couldn't respond to it they
blocked your email address immediately
um
i then thought right
i need to go and have a look at these
policies myself and see what's going on
here yeah what my rights of appeal are
so i went to log into the the
university's kind of intraness
platform i was blocked from that as well
so i couldn't access the policies
themselves
um
within a few hours
i i just had a bad feeling in the back
of my mind i don't know what it was that
told me to do this but i thought i would
just have a look at their twitter
and that same evening they posted a
tweet
stating that they had expelled a student
and stating their solidarity with the
lgbt plus community
and to anyone who was aware of what was
going on and actually you know become
quite well known what i was doing in the
space the complaints that were made
against me people would know that was me
instantaneously so as if it wasn't
enough they had ended my training and my
my future vocational hopes over an email
they thought they'd stick the boot in
and announce it on twitter
i'm i'm left speechless and and they
there was no recourse to
to complain there was no recourse to
take it further there was nothing of
that nature
i i've never had a single conversation
with anyone i've never been presented
with a single policy or piece of
evidence in this space i was never
offered an opportunity to appeal
um as i said they flouted their policies
from start to finish under the policies
there should be numerous steps including
an adjudication panel a chance to
represent myself all of this went out
the window
most strikingly was this in their policy
it talks about potential sanctions for
example when immediate expulsion would
be suitable
and the type of offences for which
immediate expulsion would be suitable
are individuals who have committed a
sexual assault on campus or defrauded
the institution
and seemingly they are comparing what's
my beliefs about safeguarding children
and about sex and gender to sexual
assault or fraud it's interesting that
you you're telling us the story because
i think to anyone listen or to most
people listening this will seem
beyond credibility how ridiculous what
you're telling us is
but we francis and i we were invited to
speak uh one of britain's best private
schools recently and when we turned up a
few of the teachers kind of went do you
want to tour the school we were like oh
yeah we'd love one and they showed us
one room and then dragged us into a pub
to tell us what was happening
at their school while looking behind
them over their shoulder every few
seconds
and i think
it seems like there are certain
institutions
where
there is a culture that exists in which
what you did was
equivalent to sexual assault in people's
minds because of how toxic this whole
conversation has become
so did this happen before you were let
go by childline or after no child line
followed a few weeks later okay
uh
childline were aware of my concerns in
this space because i wanted to be
transparent and in fact i was concerned
about some child lines practices for
example their web page on gender
identity very much reads to me and
others as kind of a road map towards
transitioning it doesn't even talk about
therapy and there's a lot of young
people that access this so i i was
asking could i input into the webpage
could i have some discussions and for a
while they entertained me and they said
they were listening to my feedback
um
i said that i wanted to publicly
identify myself as a childline
counsellor as part of my writings etc
and they said to me that they didn't
want me to do that
um
and basically there was a conversation
around that and they decided ultimately
that
they would have to let me go i i was
invited onto a video call with one of
these senior management members i
thought to discuss the possibility of me
identifying myself publicly as a
counselor because you know why shouldn't
i it's the truth i was counselling there
and he simply told me not to come in for
my next shift
uh did he explain why
he said that
what i was saying in this space and my
concerns that i was raising could put
young people off coming through to
childline in the first place
um
but i i found that very concerning
because what i was raising with him
was actually concerns about what happens
when young people are coming through to
child line what they've been exposed to
the type of counselling that they've
been offered
um
but for him this was uh
beyond the pale clearly do you think
there's some truth to that argument in
that you know you clearly
have strong views about this issue and
we've conceded during our discussion
already that there are some people for
whom transition may be the right option
and there may be young children for whom
it is eventually the right option who
may be put off
uh by the fact that someone with your
views is working as a counselor at
childline did you think there's some
merit to that argument
i don't and the reason is that from
since time immemorial therapists have
had to engage in this idea of it's
called bracketing it's basically you
know setting aside one's personal
beliefs and views on things and to deal
with the client that's in front of them
and that's how i've always operated in
childline as i said i was doing this for
five years
i i never received a mark against me in
fact i received a lot of positive
feedback including about the way i
engage with children with gender sure
but do you not see how from a
ten-year-old's perspective seeing you
being very vocal on this issue online
may cause them to think well this may be
not the organization to which i need to
go to get support
if if a young person
reading that simply wants to be affirmed
and told yes you should transition and
yes here is how you get medication then
i suppose so
for a young person who thinks
i'm struggling in myself i want somebody
who will explore this neutrally
objectively and empathetically with me
i don't see how it could
so so where are you now james with the
process
um
i was left with no choice but to start
litigation against my university course
and actually also my therapeutic
regulatory body who seemed to have had
some hand in what happened to me
and this will come out in the wash i i
suspect but yes i sought legal advice
and i was told that i had a very strong
fame for discrimination against my
beliefs in this space
uh
i had to crowd fund the money as so many
people do nowadays and
today i think i've raised just over 80
000 pounds from
concerned members of the public which is
i'm just kidding no look it's a heck
that means a hell of a lot of money
it's not going into my my back pocket it
goes straight
um but
yeah i mean the outpouring of support
and generosity from complete strangers
who owe me nothing has been fantastic
but it shows the strength of feeling in
this space actually whether it's people
who are concerned about women's rights
or the gay community or children's
well-being a huge strength of feeling so
i've instigated litigation it's it's
moving quite slowly as these things tend
to do there's some preliminary hearings
in june and then it will proceed to a
trial probably at the end of this year
at the start of next year but i'm very
much
wanting
my day in court over this and what are
you hoping to achieve
well it's become about a lot more than
just me actually to be honest
in some ways it feels that my reputation
has been kind of irreparably damaged um
and the roots towards me qualifying as a
therapist now
appear limited um for me it's about the
bigger picture actually about what this
issue represents for society
particularly around sex and gender but
also freedom of speech and council
culture and i i want to make sure that
no
institutional university is allowed to
do this to one of its students ever
again and i'm hoping that this can set a
marker actually and set a standard and
universities will think twice before
discriminating against their own
students because they'll wind up in
court
james
is there really no way back for you as a
therapist you sound like someone who is
passionate about this type of work you
sound like somebody who wants to work
with children
it just seems desperately sad that
you're not going to be able to
do this vocation
i i feel terribly sad
if i go back to childline um
that was probably the most fulfilling
part of my life and i i was going there
every week for five years and i still
sometimes walk past that building
and i
feel this wave of emotion and sadness
that i'm i'm not in there
helping these young people that i that i
care about and i want to support them
through their own journeys in life
um
i hope
that once this case resolves itself i
will be able to carry on with my
training elsewhere
um
i've not given up wanting to help people
i may just have to help them in in a
different space but but for me the
well-being of children is more important
than anything and actually
once you open your eyes to what's going
on in this space you cannot unsee it and
so i think this is going to become my
life's work one way or another even if
i've suffered personally as a result of
it
and
at this point there's no chance of you
going to another university taking up
your qualification again is that
let's say firing or shacking whatever
you want to call it is that too much of
a black mark against your name and
nobody else will want to take you on
well the therapeutic community is quite
small and everyone knows everything so
certainly until i until my name has been
cleared in a court of law i i can't see
how someone would want to take me on the
issue isn't the reason i chose this
course was because it was on weekends
and i i have a
full-time job to keep a roof over my
head i'm not in a position to go down to
a part-time role this was basically the
only course that i could do whilst also
providing for myself financially
and has this affected your job your your
full-time job
um
i i have to be careful about what i say
here because i've um
yes uh and at one point and i won't go
into any great detail on this but at one
point there was a kind of investigation
of sorts into me because a complaint was
made um to my employer
but that's resolved itself now because
they followed due process
and the right outcome i believe was was
reached but yes at one point it did look
to me like my livelihood could be under
threat as well and have have the
therapeutic community been to you have
lots of people been reaching out have
people been talking to you have they
been saying the standard things that we
get really support your work but they're
not
come out and say that i do
i've had a mix i've had a hell of a lot
of support from like-minded therapists
who have equal concerns in this space um
i've also had the opposite and it feels
that a lot of therapeutic communities
have almost become kind of activists in
their own right
um
part of my case which has been extended
is this my therapeutic body was running
a training course for therapists on
conversion therapy and the individual i
can't name them at this stage running
the training program
spent a big chunk of the training course
badmouthing me and my case and accusing
me of abusing the law and things like
that um
one of the people attending the training
happened to be recording this and sent
it through to me and this now forms part
of the basis of my case but
i found therapists who are willing to
kind of badmouth me online um i've been
shown screenshots from therapeutic
facebook groups who when they discovered
that i've been expelled we're having a
mini celebration and party a basis
um
so
i i think it depends which way one's
ideology lies but for people who are
proponents of gender ideology
uh they view my expulsion and
elimination from the profession as
something to be celebrated for the
therapists that i know who are concerned
about the well-being of children
this is a mark against the therapeutic
profession and they are feel for the
fear for themselves of
being cancelled in their own right
well we wish you all the best with the
case we hope you get you get your day in
court and uh
i know it probably doesn't feel like
this way to you right now because having
been in a similar position somewhat i
understand it's very personal and
emotional but uh over time i think
you'll see that uh this is part of the
bigger thing that you're talking about
and the stand you've taken uh will will
form part of the process of pushing back
against some of the excesses of what
you're talking about so uh all the best
to you thank you thanks for coming on
the show
uh if people want to follow your work
where do they do that
twitter i'm i'm pretty active on twitter
it's just my name james s's i've got a
sub stack where i'm writing more
in-depth pieces on this um that's called
transparency
and i've got a cryo justice page which
keeps people abridged about what's going
on with my litigation and they can
follow updates through that as well
great i look forward to finding out how
it goes and of course as always we have
one more question for you which is as
always what's the one thing we're not
talking about that we really should be
yeah so for me this is an interesting
one because i think we spent so much of
our lives talking about how we should
live
and not enough time talking about how we
should die because death is inevitable
for all of us and so that is why i'm a
strong proponent of discussions around
assisted dying um i've been a
long-standing supporter of a charity
called dignity and dying i've seen
legislation passed abroad which has
offered up assisted dying for people who
are in
the most horrific situations and who
want to die with dignity um in our
country we don't have a sister dying and
people are being forced to either
end their lives in the most most
inhumane way or take themselves off to a
dignitas clinic for example
and the fear of prosecution hanging over
themselves or their families heads um
people shouldn't suffer i form i
fundamentally believe that people should
be able to die with dignity so i think
we need to have a discussion about this
both
in house of parliament but also in
society more generally it's an
interesting point we had dr john wyatt
on the show a while ago who comes very
much from the opposite point of view uh
but yeah you're right this is an issue
that uh seems to be coming to the fore
one way or another so thanks for
bringing that to our attention we're
going to ask you a couple of questions
from our supporters that only they will
see on our locals but in the meantime
thanks for coming on the show thanks for
having me and thank you for watching and
listening we'll see you very soon with
another brilliant episode like this one
or raw show all of them go at 7 pm uk
time and for those of you who like your
trigonometry on the go it's also
available as a podcast take care and see
you soon guys
in the us at the moment i've seen a call
for potentially launching a group
lawsuit based on puberty blockers um
it's only a matter of time until that
reaches the uk